that's uh I'm kind of disappointed that
Ali Dawa couldn't be up here I didn't
tell ya I don't agree with what he
stands for but I agree this right to say
it actually got a lead over it's
happening it's happening this is
fantastic
here's the yeah the really an artist its
rahim three three ten richard in man
speaks liam toughs other Dawa shows your
hub strap button I'm worried I looked at
their next to each other there's a whole
kind of thing I've literally just been
I've been over there and they've got
like her a running order and he's on a
three-term oh no what'd you think of
that well I'm a bit you know a little
bit off about Ali so guys I just saw
their sargon of akkad who is a big
youtuber in the million subscribers was
there any defended my right to the
speech and I thank him for that even
though I disagree with him the same goes
with Lucy Caden and George I found you
guys especially Lucy for trying to
protect me as a woman on our own and
moving away from danger and the whole
team and and the restaurant thank you
guys the speech that I was going to give
on that day is the following I just want
to get straight to the point and say
this I feel of so far called voter I
said I despite what you say but will
defend to the death your right to say it
I defend the right of anyone to question
and criticize my religion on any or any
other way of life and that is the reason
why we give power to call it with Islam
so people can criticize and educate
themselves in the process of doing so
but we need to know the difference of
freedom speech and hate speech was it
not the freedom of hate speech that
eventually led to the Holocaust
Holocaust was it not the freedom of hate
speech that led to the killing of
innocent people non-muslims in London
Bridge a Manchester attacks was it not
the freedom of hate speech that led to
Thomas metaphor MP Joe Cox was it not
the freedom of hate speech of Tommy
Robinson and Britain first that caused
Darren Osborne to run over innocent
Muslims and the list goes on so if you
are here to defend
to criticize and question ideologies I
am with you but if you want the freedom
to spew hate which comes at the cost of
innocent lives then I'm against that
with all my might and power why is it
that the main focus of freedom of hate
speech defended just to attack they
slammed by the ultra-right let me ask
you all a question
which I was gonna ask the audience to
ponder upon the difference between me
and most of the speakers today is not
that I'm the only one that eats halal
meat humour there
I hate terrorism whether it's done by I
hate child exploitation not because it's
done by a majority of white middle-aged
men or advocated by Tommy's friend or
buddy my know I hate grooming gangs not
cause majority of Asian men who have
used vulnerable white girls
I hate human traffickers who are selling
young ethnic kids from country to
country
however Milo Tommy Robinson Britain
first hate terrorism only when it's done
by Muslims they hate grooming guns only
when it's done by Muslims and this to me
is sickening I hate the act not because
of who who's done it but because of what
he or she has done to destroy innocent
lives we have had these discussions on
my youtube channel which you can find by
searching Ida Dawa and hear it from a
Muslim would I go to Hitler to learn
about Judaism of course not so why go to
the people who hate Islam every
civilized society which believes in free
speech has also recognized that such
free speech has limitations free speech
should not be confused with a license to
abuse
most democracies forbid slander
defamation misleading advertisement and
freedom two rooms reveal state secrets
the argument many right-wing ultra-right
proponents are making is one which is
specially focused on the freedom to
offend minority groups the argument is
that this now has become a protected
minority rule and that free speech
should allow us to attack Islam as a
religion to counter this one could talk
internationally about Muslims being
burnt in Burma 1 million killed in Iraq
and Afghanistan or tortured in
Guantanamo Bay while the West looks on
however today I will not talk about that
or use this argue
I just wonder why the ultra-right is
disproportionately focused on Islam when
laws in this country have in fact aimed
to protect other religious groups it was
only ten years ago where actual
Christian blasphemy laws were amended
from common law Jews are protected in
many European countries from the free
speech of someone however unjustifiably
denying the Holocaust for example the
far-right has said nothing about Jews
special rights it would be interesting
to know if any of today's speakers would
want to defend someone's right to defend
the Holocaust denial the puppy burning
or burning the English flag English flag
why is that whatever the reason I don't
care as a voice of the Muslim community
I want you to know that we don't need
added rights as minorities in this
country but we do demand equal treatment
the same philosopher who championed
freedom of speech like Jay s mail Jay s
mill also championed protecting
minorities they were particularly
concerned with with what is referred to
as tyranny of the majority if we are to
be consistent we must be concerned with
the same thing today I could have as
others have accused other speakers as
being near fascist or neo-nazis I
haven't done that and I don't intend to
do that that's not productive there are
parallels between the ultra-right and
interwar Germany and Italy which you
should be aware of the ultra-right is
also ultra nationalist assimilationist
and what separates the separatists one
of the first thing that did after
putting through the Enabling Act was
passed restrictions of Jewish people the
Jewish people who he as you know thought
was the germ that was infecting society
something you know tomorrow this is my
wisdoms similar words anyways the
ultra-right stress anti-muslim
immigration the stoppage of building of
mosques and restriction of so-called
islamification Hitler told his people
the Jews and the Communists were the
ultimate problem and today the
ultra-right is saying the same thing
about Muslims and I'm gonna finish off
with this today I want to offer a
personal invitation to everyone
listening here to share your grievances
with us the Muslim community and we will
do the same with you if you want to come
to speaker's corner next week on joining
us for breaking our fasting Ramadan two
weeks from now and we can explain what
Islam is from our perspective we will
listen to your perspective and allow you
to air concerns about our community it
is in this restorative justice type set
up where we can move for
as respectful communities I thank you
for listening
that was my talk my freedom of speech
was stopped
we was attacked but we still got YouTube
and I've conveyed that message
hope you guys benefited good bye